أنشأ وزير المالية الإسرائيلي القومي
عاصفة نارية دولية بعد أن
نفى وجود
الشعب الفلسطيني والأمة الفلسطينية ، وقد
أدانت السلطة الفلسطينية
وحماس تعليقاته ، كما أثار انتقادات من
الولايات المتحدة والاتحاد الأوروبي لتصريحات وزير المالية
تأتي مع حلول شهر
رمضان المبارك.  على وشك أن أبدأ adasgow
ينضم إلي الآن على الهواء مباشرة من القدس ، لذا
سألت ما الذي تتعلمه أكثر عن
هذا وبالطبع رد الفعل على ما
قاله الوزير ،
نعم لقد تزوجت ، جاءت هذه التعليقات يوم
الأحد ، لذا قبل أيام قليلة أه
هذا كله صغير  كانت الكنيسة في باريس
تتحدث في حفل تذكاري
لناشط يميني معروف كان
أيضًا مديرًا تنفيذيًا للمنظمة الصهيونية العالمية وما
قاله سموتريتش بالأساس هو أنه يدعي أن
الهوية الفلسطينية هي فكرة
الشعب الفلسطيني الذي يدعي أنه
اخترع في القرن الماضي
على وجه التحديد كرد فعل
للحركة الصهيونية على حركة
الشعب اليهودي الراغب في تأسيس دولة
إسرائيل بحجة أن
الطيار لا يوجد لديه
ثقافة أو تاريخ فلسطيني أو أي شيء من هذا القبيل
وبالطبع هذا استقبل سريعًا جدًا
إدانة ليس فقط من
السلطة الفلسطينية ولكن أيضًا من
الأوروبيين من الأردنيين المصريين والإماراتيين الذين
كانوا يسمعون أيضًا من
الأمريكيين الذين يتحدثون ضد
هذا الأمر بعد فترة وجيزة من قول جون كيربي
من البيت الأبيض أن هذه
الأنواع من التعليقات لا تساعد في  كل ذلك
يهدئ التوترات على الأرض ، ومن
المفارقات أنه في نفس اليوم الذي كان سموتريتش
يدلي بهذه التصريحات
أعضاء إسرائيليون في الحكومة الإسرائيلية
نلتقي مع
السلطة الفلسطينية إلى جانب الأمريكيين
المصريين والأردنيين وشارما
شيخ في قمة فريدة من نوعها هي الثانية من
هؤلاء.  أنواع من القمم كجزء من محاولة لمحاولة
تهدئة الوضع على
الأرض بالطبع كنا في نوع من
دائرة العنف اللانهائية بين
الإسرائيليين والفلسطينيين خاصة
قبل شهر رمضان الذي يبدأ هذا
الأسبوع ثم عطلة عيد الفصح
بدءًا من بداية
شهر أبريل ، بينما كان جزء من
الحكومة الإسرائيلية يبذل جهودًا لتهدئة
الوضع من خلال
إصدار بيان خاص يتحدث عن محاولة
تهدئة الخطاب والأشياء
التي لا يمكن إلا أن تؤدي إلى تفاقم الوضع
لعضو رفيع المستوى
تقوم الحكومة الإسرائيلية بالعكس تمامًا
الآن ، هناك عنصر آخر تسبب في حدوث
عاصفة نارية وهو حقيقة أنه على
المنصة حيث كان يتحدث سموتريتش
كان يبدو وكأنه
علم إسرائيلي يحمل صورة إذا كنت
تعرفه  إنها خريطة ممتدة
لإسرائيل تحب بعض الجماعات المتطرفة
استخدامها والتي لا تشمل
إسرائيل الحالية فحسب ، بل تشمل أيضًا غزة
والضفة الغربية المحتلة وحتى أجزاء
مهمة ، وبالطبع لدى الأردن وإسرائيل معاهدة
سلام ، فهما
تربطهما علاقات دبلوماسية  لذلك تسبب هذا في
عاصفة نارية مع الأردنيين أه
تسبب في قيام مستشار الأمن القومي الإسرائيلي تاهي
إيجبي بالاتصال
بالأردنيين وطمأنتهم بأن إسرائيل
ملتزمة بمعاهدة السلام مع
الأردن ، إنه فقط يظهر لك
نوعًا من  الفوضى في
الحكومة الإسرائيلية الآن حيث تقوم
يد واحدة بعمل شيء آخر بإصدار هذه
أه هذه التصريحات ومن ناحية أخرى
لديك حكومة إسرائيلية
تحاول الحفاظ على معاهدات السلام هذه
والحفاظ على هذا التواصل المستمر أه
مع
السلطة الفلسطينية تنضم روزماري أديسكو  نحن
نعيش من القدس شكرا جزيلا على هذا
التقرير